[Music]
if you've been watching Disney movies
since you were a kid then you've
probably noticed a theme stay tuned for
the crazy reasons that most Disney
Princesses don't have a mom are you new
around here don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and subscribe to
the things for more great content like
this now onto the sad reason why all
Disney Princesses don't have a mom do
you have daddy issues we can probably
all remember curling up in front of the
television to watch a Disney movie as a
kid the tales of princesses and princes
good and evil dragons and knights were
all that we saw when watching these
films most of us focused on the good
parts every princess in each movie got a
happy ending so it was easy to forget
the parts of their lives that weren't so
pretty like the fact that Cinderella was
basically a slave for the majority of
her life seriously she lived in an attic
and couldn't come out and see the Sun
unless she was working for one of her
stepsisters or stepmom the girl had it
rough Snow White's life wasn't a walk in
the park either her stepmom literally
tried to get rid of her she had to run
away and live in a cottage with seven
men to stay alive that doesn't sound too
great does it despite all getting happy
endings there is one other thing that
binds all of these Disney Princesses
together and it's much darker than
finding a prince and living happily ever
after the majority of Disney princesses
don't have mothers think about it
Ariel no mom Snow White no mom
Cinderella no mom jasmine Pocahontas
Tiana all of them don't have biological
moms have you ever thought about this
could the reason be simply a coincidence
is something still a coincidence when it
happens almost every time well there are
a lot of theories out there that suggest
that there is a pretty messed-up reason
as to why most of these princesses don't
have moms the first has to do with Walt
Disney's relationship with his own mom
what happened to his mother was actually
pretty tragic
in the 1940s Walt Disney bought a house
for his parents he had obviously come
into some money and wanted to share the
wealth with his parents when they moved
in the furnace was on the fritz Walt had
some people from his studio go to the
house and fix the furnace unfortunately
the furnace continued to leak when the
housekeeper came in one more
she had to pull his mother and father
out of the home Walt's mother passed
away from this incident and his father
ended up in the hospital everyone who
knew wall around this time said that he
never spoke about what happened to his
parents he completely felt responsible
even though it wasn't necessarily his
fault he had tried to do something nice
for his parents and unfortunately it
didn't turn out well the studio workers
who went to the house to fix the furnace
weren't trained on how to do it and
didn't know what they were doing many
people say that Walt was haunted by the
incident because of this it may have
been too painful for him to include
mothers in his movies or to focus on
mother child relationships at all
instead he preferred to completely keep
mothers out of his film another theory
focuses on how Disney movies tend to be
coming-of-age stories we follow most of
the princesses as they grow up and come
into their own
why Erik run away with you this theory
says that a child is never an adult
until they assume the role that their
parents would normally take by not
giving the characters mother figures
Walt set them to grow up right before
our eyes
this theory is a lot less bleak than the
first one so we won't blame you if this
is the one that you want to believe this
theme has been showcased in lots of
movies and shows even outside of the
Disney World from Harry Potter to Game
of Thrones this idea is one that is
quite popular our next theory is also
much lighter than the first two
another common thread between all of the
Disney Princesses is that they make
mistakes they stumble and fall through
most of the beginning of their stories
in order to have a triumphant victory by
the end without their initial mistakes
there would hardly be any story to tell
well some people believe that if Walt
had given each of these girls mothers
they wouldn't have made half as many
mistakes as they did think about it when
you're headed down the wrong path and
about to make a huge error who's the one
that usually puts you back on track your
mom right moms have a weird sixth sense
about these things
so if a mom had been there to tell Ariel
not to trade her voice and soul to an
evil witch just staying out with a boy
there wouldn't have been a film if
Cinderella's mom had been there then
there would not have been an evil
stepmother in her life and no reason for
her to go to the ball it's no
White's mother had been around she never
would have had to flee the castle and
never would have met those Seven Dwarfs
basically the mothers would have ruined
the stories there just wasn't a place
for them to fit in now there are a few
exceptions to this role Merida and
Rapunzel Merida's relationship with her
mother is kind of the center of brave
Rapunzel's relationship with her
stepmother is also the center of tangled
but each of these relationships isn't
exactly healthy in brave Merida's mom
wants her to be something other than
what she is her mom spent the whole
first portion of the movie trying to
force Merida to change everything we
never had I asked you what do you expect
us to do sure the to do mend their
relationship throughout the film but we
can definitely tell that Merida and her
mom were at odds for most of her life
the relationship between Rapunzel and
her mom is even weirder first of all the
lady in the film is not actually
Rapunzel's mom at all but actually a
witch who pretty much kidnaps Rapunzel
when she's a baby she then hides
Rapunzel in a tower where she obsesses
over her and tells her how great she is
but doesn't let her leave it's a really
sick relationship so even the princesses
who do have mothers don't have the best
relationships with them which makes it
extremely clear that something was up
with Walt and his ideas of motherhood we
wonder if the new generation of Disney
movies and princesses will keep up this
theme or if modern times will force
Disney to start adding mothers into the
films what do you think and that's it
for the sad reason why all Disney
Princesses don't have a mom which theory
do you believe let us know in the
comments below see you next time
[Music]